[Music]
if you keenly observe every kid has
characters taking from the parents yes
characters from both mom and dad have
you ever wondered why this happens why
do we find random characters in the kids
which belong to the same parents in
simple language we can say that it is
because of the sexual reproduction in
organisms yes
although the logical reasoning can be
provided by genetics we will not really
get into the details of it we will
restrict ourselves to the major process
responsible for this now you may wonder
as to how sexual reproduction can be
responsible for the variations in
organisms for this we need to stop by
the definition of sexual reproduction
once again do you remember what it was
let me help you sexual reproduction is
the type of reproduction which involves
fusion of gametes to give rise to new
individual now here the term fusion of
gametes is the answer to a question why
is that so this is because if we say
that the zygote is formed with the
fusion of gametes then it means the
newly formed individual will have a
blend of characters does an order to
learn sexual reproduction we need to
understand that gametes first gametes
are sex cells and are different in both
males and females do you know what
they're called yes we have come across
these terms the male gamete is called
sperm while the female gamete is called
ovum in order to study them we first
need to take a glance at the
reproductive systems this will give us
an idea of how the gametes are produced
and help us understand the fertilization
process better so in this video let us
learn about the male reproductive system
to begin with we take a look at the
location where the sperms are exactly
produced these oval-shaped structures on
either side are the ones we are
referring to
the single structure is called testes
while the pair is called testes or
simply a pair of testicles now these are
an important part of the system and need
to be protected right so we have a
covering of skin over it this forms a
bag like structure and do we have a name
for it yes the bag like structure is
called the scrotum so the scrotum is the
pouch which contains the testes
now the sports traduced will have to
travel in order to reach the female body
so who will make sure that the sperms
are carried outside the testes this
responsibility is taken up by the
massive coils that we can see here this
is called the epididymis and the pair is
called the epididymis the mass then
carries the sperms to this single
connecting long coil this is called the
vas deferens
where will the deferens carried further
directly outside the body no they will
carry to do something called as the
ejaculatory ducts but where does the
ejaculatory duct head - it heads to a
destination where the sperms get mixed
with the nourishing fluid wait a second
what kind of fluid are we referring to
and why is it needed here basically the
spawns need nourishment to survive also
they need to be protected from acidic
conditions coming their way
hence various glands come to the rescue
by secreting a few important secretions
the first one is the seminal vesicle it
secretes a fluid that helps in
nourishing the sperms can you see this
bud like structure here it is the
prostate gland which helps in secreting
the prostate fluid now the sperms
floating in the fluids reach the urethra
from where they can be released outside
the body but wait all the secretions are
not yet completed this B shaped gland
found here gives another important
secretion it is called the Cooper's
gland or even the bubble urethral gland
now with
secretion the formation of semen is
complete the semen is simply the fluid
carrying the sperms it is carried out by
the urethra which runs through the penis
now these pumps will reach the female
reproductive system and only one among
all will be able to carry out the
fertilization of the ovum but tell me
one thing looking at the structure of
the single sperm can you guess whether
it is a unicellular or a multicellular
structure it is a single cell although
the structure may not seem to be that of
a single cell the sperm is definitely
unicellular it bears a head region
called the nucleus then it has this
middle part with the mitochondria for
providing energy to swim across but then
who will help in the swimming process
physically that's the business of the
steel region the tail helps in the
swimming activity now we are done with
the basics of the male reproductive
system
let me quickly recap the process we saw
above the sperms are produced by the
testes the massive coils called the
epididymis carries the sperms to the vas
deferens which is a long coil from there
it goes to the ejaculatory duct where it
gets mixed with nourishing fluids from
there it reaches the urethra and after
the secretion from the Koopas gland the
formation of semen is complete so what
will we learn before the fertilization
process of course the female
reproductive system do watch our next
video to learn more about it
[Music]